[Music]
new at 11 tonight a new kind of
courtroom opened its doors in north las
vegas it's all meant to make the court
process easier for people who might not
be able to go during the day orco mana
takes us inside the city's first ever
night court
if you get a traffic ticket here in
north las vegas you have to come to
municipal court to take care of it but
for the first time ever you can come
after hours welcome to night court
a classic courtroom operating beyond the
business day north las vegas municipal
court held its first session of night
court tuesday it's the first of its kind
in nevada and the focus is on traffic
violations not a yearling that was
marcos diaz's offense but he says taking
care of traffic tickets is not easy
because of his schedule i'm a commercial
driver so like it gets busy during the
day and you know i got evenings off
that's why he's thankful for night court
you know you can actually have time to
come in and
handle your what you got to do we're
talking about increasing access to
justice judge chris lee handles the
cases for night court which right now
will happen about once a month he says
it's a natural expansion of north las
vegas community approach to
rehabilitation and engagement or care
court program which focuses on the root
cause of a violation they heard
countless stories about
why their tickets went into warrant and
and often times it was because they just
couldn't make it to court to resolve
their court case judge lee says
resolving issues during night court can
prevent warrants from affecting
someone's record and even job prospects
to kind of stop that cascading negative
effect and there's a chance nightcore
could expand to other minor violations
trespassing the open container some some
of that diaz likes the idea it's awesome
you know to have evening courts judge
lee says he'll look at how the first few
nights go to decide if any changes need
to be made moving forward reporting in
north las vegas orco mana live local now